wer bei shampoo
jede seite
er weiß schon heute wogen sind immer
wieder alles neu beginnt
hey leute wir sind heute im tierheim wir
haben diesen wunderschönen hund an der
autobahnraststätte gefunden des
herrchens nicht aufzufinden aber die
wissen was zu tun ist ein
wir haben jetzt die suppe gefunden habe
ich bin der sufis tierpflegerin und wird
uns hoffentlich helfen mit unserem
kleinen freund hier die frage erst mal
zwei wochen ab ob sich die besitzer
melden und wenn sich in zwei wochen
keiner gemeldet hat dann werden wir
schauen dass wir einen guten platz für
den kunden zwei wochen und kannst du uns
sagen wo er jetzt quasi untergebracht
dann kommt in die quarantäne station
nein kann man leider nicht weil
quarantäne halte nicht umsonst fiat
bereich ist auch da werden sind die
ganzen team tiere behandelt so geht es
jetzt in die runde wie die hunde gehen
der 100
genau das ist ein bereich von der hunde
wg die wir haben drei gucken das sind
eher sie die kleinen bis mittelgroßen
hundes muss man natürlich immer schauen
dass es so zusammenfasst vom gegen hier
an temperament das kosten hoffen geld
wahrscheinlich so für viel geld
mir wird es finanzhilfen ein teil trägt
die stadt münchen dazu bei einem
hauptsächlich tschechische spendengelder
finanziert die leute seiner für wendigen
oder eine katze mitnehmen und die leute
noch seinen hund abgeben was viele nicht
wissen und was wahrscheinlich auch ein
grund ist warum dann doch einige auch
ausgesetzt werden sie ist das eigentlich
bei soviel hunden
er geht mit dem gast
das machen ehrenamtliche leute die zeit
haben viele rentnerinnen spezielles mit
hoch das ist so eine art friedhof werden
direkt nebenan haben wir das krematorium
wenn er die tiere eingeäschert und von
der agip eben einiges auch hier wo die
leute dann fotos hinstellen können im
prinzip als gedenkstätte
jetzt wird 40 und zuckersüß wir gehen zu
den kleinen tieren
der steht dir gut ist es so sein
hauptberuf oder also ich arbeite hier
werde auch gefallen ich warte aber
eigentlich auf einen studienplatz für
medizin ist nicht so ganz so leicht
reinzukommen und in der zwischenzeit
arbeite ich hier und ich finde dass mir
gute überbrückung in der man schon mal
einiges lernt vorbereitung und dein
lieblingstier mit abstand die hunde
früher meerschweinchen und ratten aber
ich wollte immer hunde haben hat die man
nicht erlaubt und jetzt habe ich die
eigene wohnung und habe drei